what's up guys
helen here to talk about the film that
convinced you to create a new fake gmail
account so you could try to nap another
one of those
recently discontinued hbo max trials
that's right
wonder woman 1984. now like most of you
we were big fans of the first wonder
woman and were naturally stoked about
the sequel
and while plenty of people thought the
movie was fun mothers were a little
disappointed
and while people might want to nitpick
plot holes or action sequences
we at wisecrack thought we'd try to
learn something about screenwriting
by asking the question wonder woman 1984
what went wrong and of course spoilers
ahead for a brand new movie and a rather
old british story
but before we get into it i wanted to
take a second to tell you about
wisecrack's patreon page
which is sort of like a secret island of
highly trained amazons
but for people who can't help but search
for meaning in pop culture
so nothing like a secret island of
highly trained amazons
but hey you can join for as little as
two dollars which is also how much it
cost for a set of snap bracelets back in
1984.
along with early access to ad-free
versions of all of our videos
patrons have access to our discord a
place to compare notes about recent
videos
share memes that only a wisecrack fan
would get and to chat with wisecrack
hosts and writers about what they're
watching
reading and playing it also gets you
access to exclusive hangouts
where we talk about recent videos what
we're currently working on
and occasionally chat about our ideal
lunches so go to patreon.comwisecrack or
click the link in the description to
join today
oh and did we mention ad-free videos
that's patreon.comwisecrack
and now back to the show and now a quick
recap
wonder woman 1984 finds diana living in
that glitzy decade working as an
archaeologist at the smithsonian
there she and her anxious supposedly
unlikable new friend barbara study a
seemingly worthless stone that promises
to grant wishes
each lady makes a wish diana that her
dead boo steve was still alive
and barbara that she was more like diana
and surprise
their wishes come true but the stone is
stolen by badminton max gold
who basically wishes for a thousand
wishes i wish
to be you the dream stone
itself but of course there's a catch the
stone giveth and it also taken
diana loses her powers barbara her
humanity and max the moist air entering
his nostrils
oh and maybe also his kid then max goes
full
oprah on wish granting sending the world
into chaos
and it's up to wonder woman to stop him
not with violence but
with the truth
now lots of people have their various
reasons for liking or disliking this
film
but we think one of the best ways to
look at the film's falls is through its
central narrative engine
the monkey's paw now it doesn't take a
film studies degree to see what the film
is trying to say
it's pretty clearly telegraphed in the
opening flashback which sees a young
diana try to win
an amazonian race by taking a shortcut
sneaky shortcuts robin wright warns us
equal very very bad you cheated diana
that is the truth that is the only truth
and truth is all there
is anyway this quickly becomes a lens to
view the greed is good mentality of the
1980s
or america's general love of get rich
quick schemes and grifters
do you have everything you've ever
wanted
aren't you tired of always wishing you
had more
get it cheating your way into wealth is
just as bad as cheating in an amazon
race
and it's up to diana to set the record
straight this world was a beautiful
place just as it was
and you cannot have it all
you can only have the truth now for many
at wisecrack
this moment felt a little dumb like
after hearing those words
bernie madoff wept a single tear and
apologized to all of his victims
but part of the reason it might have
felt hollow is the nature of the wishing
stone itself
supposedly created by some sinister god
all we know is that
it is indeed a trick which gives you
your wish while also taking away
something very important to you
in this way the stone is indeed a
monkey's paw
as steve rightly points out while
casually possessing the apartment
body and genitals of an innocent
unsuspecting engineer
but what even is a monkey's paw well
that term just so happens to come from a
short story of the same
name by british writer w w jacobs
published in 1902
the tale chronicles the unfortunate
events that befall one family
after they wish upon their friends
shriveled little monkey appendage
despite being warned by said friend to
pitch it on the fire
again like a sensible man the patriarch
of the family who notes that he has
basically everything he needs in life
wishes for 200 pounds because why dream
big right
the next day their son dies in a factory
accident
and the couple receives 200 pounds in
whoopsies money from his employers
the distraught matriarch convinces her
husband to use the second wish
to bring their son back to life but upon
hearing the zombified son knocking at
the door
the spooked out dad uses the third wish
to kill him again
yes that's the end and the moral of the
story
careful what you wish for the whole
thing is basically a screed about not
messing with fate
if the old man upstairs wants you to
have 200 bucks to blow on funko pops he
would have already turned your hot water
back on
it has since obviously become a trope
this aftershave made women want me but
it also made me impotent
so how does wonder woman botch this
trope well if we consider the original
simian wish fulfiller
some of wonder woman's problems reveal
themselves in the story
the father's wish is granted at the
literal expense of his son's death
thus punishing him for wishing for
anything in the first place
his son dies he earns 200 bucks wish
granted you dummy
and next time don't [ __ ] with fate the
monkey's paw often works best when it
uses narrative events to show the
character
that the thing they want i.e wish for is
not the thing
they need i.e lose
[Music]
now that's fitting because a key
screenwriting rule is to establish your
character's want
versus their need your poor character
spends the whole movie pursuing
their want only to learn at the end that
the conflicting need
is more important like how in the 1988
tom hanks classic big
he wants to grow up but needs to learn
to appreciate his childhood
monkey's paws are a supernatural vehicle
to get characters to realize
sometimes tragically what they really
need instead of what they originally
want and this brings us to the thing
about wonder woman that kinda bums us
out
that's because the movie has very little
of the cause and effect that can make
monkeys paul's stories compelling
the bialyan king of crude's dilemma is
probably the closest we get to a real
monkey's paw situation
he asks to get his land back this
results in a wall being built
i wish for things one cannot attain like
one
all of my land to be returned wish
granted
but that wall cuts tons of people off
from their homes and water supply
and makes them want to kill him we get
real narrative consequences of his
actions
are real careful what you wish for with
some extra poetic justice
but even that's a little sloppy the
movie slaps on the additional
consequence of max stealing his security
team
diana's trade-off is a little more
nonsensical it seems like the filmmakers
wanted to say
diana wants her lover back but she needs
to accept the truth and not cheated
anything
ever and i swear to god diana if you
even think about hustling men at bars
with arm wrestling challenges
the universe will take away your power
so fast
if bringing back your dead lover and
consequently losing your powers
seems a little random well it is the
idea is basically just lazily
shoehorning the story into the classic
superhero dilemma of
how do you get laid more than once every
50 years while also successfully saving
the world
now this dilemma is perfectly embodied
in the narrative of tobey maguire era
spider-man
which puts superhero ink into inherent
conflict with being with mary jane
she looks at me every day mary jane
watson
oh boy she only knew how i felt about
her
but she can never know but in this film
it doesn't actually develop
diana's wish doesn't cause a chain of
events that happen to take away her
powers
it's just a magical trade-off we have to
kind of accept
and so when diana ugly cries over giving
up steve and instantly becoming strong
it feels kind of meh
for the film's main characters the
monkey's paw functions less as a be
careful what you wish for because it
might come true
and much more of a haphazard trading one
good thing for one random shitty thing
this is pretty clear in barbara's
trajectory now early on her character is
depicted as a pathetic loser who
magically becomes hot likeable and able
to walk in heels
but for wishing to be like diana the
monkey's paw takes its payment in the
form of
stealing her humanity aka turning her
into a stone-cold violent [ __ ]
but what's her sin in the first place
accidentally wishing to be an immortal
superhero
see her initial wish unlike asking for a
nuclear arsenal or free money
seems so much less problematic i do know
what i'd wish for
to be like diana she doesn't want to be
suddenly famous
she just wants to be strong sexy and
liked by her co-workers
not even in a black mirror-esque
obsessed with your social score way
just like a normal human way her powers
are completely accidental to the wish
so what really is the message that she
needs to just accept being sad lonely
barbara about whom the office bros
needlessly talk [ __ ]
now maybe the message is that barbara
needs to learn self-confidence the hard
way
by scrolling through the social skills
reddit or going to an out-of-network
therapist once a week
but the film doesn't say that instead
diana is all
cause you're not the only one who
imagined the world where
everything was different basically
the message feels like barbara should
have just been content with her lot
again just kind of weird and even a
little mean and
what only amazonians get to be popular
it's worth noting that the monkey's paw
mechanics at the end of the film
are a little bit better people want
unearned stuff with no regards for the
consequences
and in mass this narratively launches
the world into a nuclear war
soviet's early detection system had
picked up our new nukes
what new nukes 100 warheads just went
online
ready to launch they're taking this as
an act of war
prepping to return fire so greed is bad
yay but perhaps the strangest thing of
all there
actually is a pretty interesting
monkey's paul situation for diana
that's baked right into the plot now
we're not typically in the business of
suggesting punch-ups but indulges
this once the screenwriter's choice to
bring steve back to life in another
man's body
has confounded the internet and made us
a little existentially concerned
is this guy still alive while this
stone-cold hottie lives breathes and
sexes in his body
is he stuck in the white man's sunken
place it's never explained
and wonder woman despite supposedly
being the greatest most moralist person
in the world
seriously doesn't seem to give a [ __ ]
about romantically borrowing the body of
a dude who is for all intents and
purposes
spiritually blackout drunk but it
actually really easily could have been
explained
the real monkey's paw consequence all
along could have been that steve
possessing another man's body
was the careful what you wish for that
is to say diana's real struggle could
have been whether or not she could
possibly live with herself
if she brought steve back to life at the
expense of a by all accounts
perfectly nice seeming engineer with a
messy apartment
she wants her boyfriend back but she
needs to abide by her moral code of not
doing a get out
i want your eye man
but the most interesting consequence of
bringing steve back to life is entirely
and very awkwardly ignored instead the
stakes are incongruently just about
diana losing her powers
and convincing everyone in the world to
accept their lot because messing with
fate can ruin
your body mind soul etc and for everyone
else's wants and needs
barbara wants to be cool but learns that
she needs to accept being a nerd because
the alternative is being a huge bit
steve wants to be with diana but he
needs to be dead
max gold wants a ton of wealth but
learns that he needs
his health oh and also on top of that
he seems to randomly realize that he
also super needs his son
a revelation that is basically mandated
by diana's lasso of truth
so not exactly the most exciting
character growth
while the film has been hailed in some
reviews as being hopeful and optimistic
about human nature
all we're really seeing is a superhero
film in which the superhero makes the
world a better place by
magically convincing all humans to stop
being greedy over the span of a mediocre
speech that sounds like a yoga teacher's
instagram caption i mean if your
suspension of disbelief wasn't already
broken
it surely was now we're not saying that
every superhero film
needs to be cranky about human nature in
the end but this movie puts a
rose-colored lens over an
ultimately kind of no actually very
cynical world view
which is that we should accept the
shitness of our given lives because as
diana puts it
and you cannot have it all
you can only have the truth
and the truth is enough the film wants
to put forward a critique of american
avarice
get rich quick schemes and the hucksters
that run them but it needs to figure out
how to do that so that wishing to be
likable isn't a cardinal sin what's more
diana's speech just feels kind of
off the truth in this imaginary 1984
world
certainly doesn't seem beautiful the
president is a daughtering fool who just
wants more nukes
what is there to wish for but more more
nuclear weapons more than they have
closer to them if i just had that in
place
then they would have to listen to us the
middle east is a very simplistically
rendered
show and there's plenty of domestic
violence for good measure
the world may be pretty beautiful if
you're a hot superhero amazonian
but expecting everyone else to agree
feels like
even now patronizing me
did wonder woman 1984 miss the
proverbial mark
and if so was it because of the bizarre
monkey's paw plotline
or are we just grumpy because of the
vaccine rollout
let us know in the comments big thanks
to all our patrons for your support
hit that subscribe button like your
christian wig pretty viciously
assaulting a low-key sex predator
and ring that bell like it's still
christmas and as always
thanks for watching peace
[Applause]
[Music]
you